[Music]
there's a lot of rising talent in the
United States how do you see the future
of American chess yeah things are going
great for American chess I mean I
definitely think the St Louis chess club
has contributed a lot to that uh since
it opens its doors in 2008 has provided
so many opportunities good tournaments
for young players lots of supports
United States the best country in the
world to be a chess professional right
now so we have very strong up-and-coming
players I see it at the like chess camps
that I'm teaching that it's becoming
really crowded and we can see like how
many talents are going to come out of
that so I think maybe in 10 15 years
it's going to be even more crowded than
it's now every generation of American
players has had so much more opportunity
than the one that came before it I know
that I had so much more than all the
people who mentored me and the ones
coming after me have so much more than I
did and the ones coming out for them
will have so much more further and you
know the United States has produced some
pretty strong players you know we've got
Ray Robson and myself and Icarus and
three guys over 2700 that you know the
US has produced from day one and uh and
yeah I think that we have a very future
ahead with all of our up-and-coming
youngsters I think um it's it's really
great to see what is happening with
chess here in St Louis the opportunities
for the junior players I think right now
at least as we look at this event in the
women's field specifically there's Alice
Lee who's 14 years old and certainly
she's a very bright future ahead of her
just in general for the players who are
younger the players who haven't had
these opportunities to compete against
the best players it's really something
special for them and I think it's really
good in terms of furthering American
Trust I think American chess has been
growing the last decade a lot I keep
hearing from players around my age
complaining how at the open tournaments
there are so many kids and they're also
underrated and they all play so well but
of course for the future it's great the
US has a strong team and for the last
couple of years I think they're
supporting especially the Young
Generation with a lot of tournaments in
Saint Louis
and I think we are going to see a lot of
Juniors to shine in the world
competition so yeah they have bright
future in my opinion well I think the
Young Generation they're insanely strong
and they're working hard they're playing
a lot of tournaments this is really
great that we have these tournaments
where the very top players get to
interact with up-and-coming players we
have um and for women's chess we also
have some very players like obviously
who's playing here she's I think she's
still only 13 she's 23.60. for me
personally that I'm a newcomer to
American chess it's a graduate to see so
many talented kids you know it's a
they're up and coming
to
[Music]
Mishra and also Alice Lee
they're extremely talented and they're
very very young so
I think the future is bright
you could probably have like three
really strong Olympia teams if we were
allowed to send three teams in the
future yeah I think it's great obviously
I think the chess club has definitely a
part to do with that just incentivizes
young players to really think that there
is a path in professional pursuing
professional chess yeah I think there's
a long way for us to go there's a lot of
potential it's going really well there's
a lot of young players you mentioned
Alice Lee
today I played on a team with her in
online chess event for the St Louis
archbishops and she beat a 2700 rated
player so she's she's done that before I
mean she beat another like super Grand
Master very recently so I think we'll
see a lot of like 2600 plus players from
that group 2600 maybe some 2700 plus
players as well and maybe some future
top players as well uh I think
definitely
um like my peers and the people slightly
older uh are definitely like really
strong I think that American chess has
like um really bright I know that chess
itself has become super popular lately
and for me to see like a lot of my
classmates who wouldn't normally be
playing chess uh start playing chess in
class for in free time I feel like that
indicates that because of the popularity
of American chess is growing more people
will start to play and as a result we
will definitely see a lot of new strong
players in the Next Generation overall
like us chess uh St Louis chess club is
doing a great job in like advertising
the how like chess can be like really
great uh super fun to play and overall
yeah I think that um American chess
definitely has a really bright future
[Music]
foreign